[Music]
hi
my name is yasuo i am guest dancer
in schoolnet dance theater in malmo in
sweden but i'm from south korea
[Music]
when i dance i feel more freedom
and then that's why i start to dance
and i think by dancing i can
i'm able to see myself as it
is like more before i fell
kind of i could i don't want to see my
see my body
itself but after i start
to dance i feel more confident
on my body yeah i think the biggest
motivation is
being freedom and
being confident
i was one of the dancers in production
of
uncharted in my mind sweden
this summer 2019 it's about the
unexpected body in unexpected places
so we perform in three different places
in three different places there's a lot
of audience like
more over 400 people
came to our performance to see
our our dance so
i think the biggest achievement is
we are exploring exposed to many
people and then we got a lot of good
feedback that
all which is this this production and
this project has to be
more and more in the public so that
people can see
i think people interpret
interpretate in many different ways
but for example i got a goody feedback
that
it's cool to see no matter what we have
a different
difficulty in our bodies i think that's
the biggest
achievement
[Music]
i want to try out the dancing
out of chair since i'm in a region for
many many years
i want to try out without chair how
movement i can do how achievable
achievement that i can get
from the performance and yeah so far i
did
many duets and trios and quattro
in a group dancing i wanted to develop
myself as a soloist
i hope audience can see
the beauty how beauty
can be diverse and colorful
with different skills and with a
different movement
by
different body because there's a lot of
social stigma
toward what is the
normal body but
i want to end as a dancer i want to
challenge
that kind of view and
i want to show that this is another
beauty
you